[Music]  race van der Waal returns to the  America's Got Talent stage when I  auditioned it's like this is what it's  worth the 13 year old powerhouse singer  who won the competition last season  dazzled the audience singing her new  single moonlight grace performed during  night two of the quarterfinals where  seven out of 12 remaining acts made it  through to the next round of competition  fans were pretty shook seeing fan  favorites Angelica Halen Darcy Lynne up  against each other the next act going  into the semifinals is both of you  et was with both young stars on Tuesday  after they performed I mean how does it  feel to get all this love from the  judges and from everyone at home  absolutely amazing and huge stage I was  so nervous but then once the crowd you  know started cheering in you know  applausing and yelling I think I got my  power and I was like I didn't do this  [Music]